they hide all the puppies oh happy my
gosh
I know you want them all right I do I
can't do it okay so are you a big sports
ball fan Oh huge you are it will as are
you right because you love sports so
love it okay but wait we really pause
and pick up the crap it's a real thing
no no no wait you're right your key
played by your chick I just met no I
can't I will smell gone this entire you
know okay so you love sports but like me
but do you just Jack watch Sheila boy
just yeah yeah yeah we both don't
understand it he might understand he's
seven he I think he understands it a
little bit better than I do better than
my kids yeah I mean there's these things
their yards I don't know they seem a
yellow flags that go down or whatever
but little would hold it down Kelly I am
your guest I'm interested in what I have
to say but your sports ball you're
climbing on my team are you wanting up
are you wanting up yet oh yeah he
doesn't really understand it buddy like
he's entertained by it yeah yeah yeah
I'm back puppy distraction idiot look at
he's climbing yeah oh you want to be out
of my team I know okay you're not though
she's fluff is there anything you felt
this is my real question because I
remember I was talking on your podcast
I love unqualified and I remember yeah
I'm I loved it and is there anything you
felt like you were ill-prepared for with
kids cuz there's so many for me I mean
to be honest kind of nothing no no no no
that was a terrible delivery of
everything and especially in Los Angeles
there's a whole school system I went to
public school how did you yeah and boy
but if you're trying to get your kids
not promised quite like a and they tell
you even when you're pregnant here like
there will be people that like creep
into your lives that are like
oh well you got to like get enrolled now
and you're like for what for it's in my
womb yeah and like good like what's
wrong with and then it's like well but
if you don't get em in the school then
they won't get into the car it's and
he's just gonna fail in life yeah right
and it's like he's already going to fail
in life this school is I don't talk
about therapy spend a ton of money to
ensure this reality wherever you are I'm
sure he's watching whatever you are
whatever's happening inside this mitt
feels soft and warm and kind of sexy man
I need a boyfriend that is the word on
the street
maybe this bras gonna change my whole
dating life wearing it for a couple of
days gotten any feelers just me for
right now
[Applause]
big game that was on it in the show mom
which you can see Thursdays on CBS so on
of the show is in its seventh season
that's awesome
yes like to let you know we're coming in
like friends territory well I mean I
feel like I could buy a small boat
friends boat but it's a small I don't
know 19-footer will you come on my boat
I would come on your boat let's see this
is the podcast on your buddy I don't
know how to pilot it I can actually
drive a boat tensional growling okay
yeah you know it watch it over there
sorry has to happen thank you Dan no
putting them in line no problem yeah
y'all Dante your fave - um I actually
really love Dante and very nervous my
husband is so nervous backstage not
another dog Dante's got anything the ego
is too is too big look at him I love him
though I need ears he just wants it okay
so I love that with mom though you
actually tackle it's a comedy but you
tackle some pretty dark issues yeah yeah
good I think if they laugh you know it
the diction but no no I love I love
doing the the show I love it that we get
to take on we it's a funny show and that
we get to be dramatic and real and it
seems to be really touching people which
is because it is real-life situations
and it's you have to laugh at some point
anybody struggling with anything at some
point you have to laugh and then build a
bridge but you just have to laugh at a
funeral that's what I always say oh my
gosh this is actually real I either go
like oh I don't even know the person
like I am just so sad like at a funeral
or I get Church giggles I get the
giggles and I just get like a sewing
comforting what does this all mean I
think starts getting very dark because
I'm sure you guys all want to hear I was
on your podcast and : thank you for
doing that
I loved it though but tell everybody
what it's about
I do this podcast called unqualified and
it's a relationship podcast and we give
people relationship advice attempt to
because I'm really bad at it cuz I don't
know what I'm doing and I wish you'd
swear because I would emphasize that
more but yeah but maybe the dogsville is
there anyone know that you feel like on
your because people who's asked me now
that I'm a show is it anybody anyway I'm
dying to have on is there anyone you're
dying to have on your podcast little Kim
look him I love you right now that's
awesome like most people would be like
you guys can feel it yeah well okay the
first the first red carpet I walked it
was for the MTV Movie Awards and little
Kim was right behind me and she was just
wearing what do they call those things
yeah yeah thanks tease somebody knew
that right away she's got some all right
now it's all ready that's how we roll oh
you can't eat the flowers of course I
psycho I love it get it okay dontay you
got another flag on the play coming bro
you're gonna be gonna vomit you
shouldn't eat that so see you'd love to
have her on your show yes yeah she'd be
interesting should be a cool guest I
mean if we get her because it'll be with
your help I will we are sending out a
pigeon right now
Lil Kim you know getting qualified I did
it's amazing I'll do it with you yeah
there you go yeah
pasties are no we will accept you anyway
Pacey's anything you want to wear yeah
everyone is welcome that was gone tattoo
you need to calm down man okay I hear
that you gave my producers a request I
did want to host your show for just a
minute well we got a switch nights all
right okay are you sure okay this one
lower I feel like it's lower anyway okay
Kelly
yeah you so much for being here it's a
busy schedule because I love you know
it's you so much Julie it's very I'm a
huge fan as an honor ditto
so I have to ask you I am exhausted
doing one podcast interview you know a
week so you do this show every day well
my show every day and what is your
secret I was just asked this and I feel
like it was around my mom cuz my mom and
it's saying you've always been like this
like in high school I had like four jobs
and I was always doing stuff like at
school like student counselor and you
know a musical or something and Dante's
crazy definitely definitely
once a rambunctious home that one
favorite musical I did Betty but I I'd
say my favorite was probably seven
bright Seven Brothers I love swing
Millie you know what it was this is
actually interesting I've never totally
mini this good job interviewing I I was
doing Seven Brides for some brothers
what it was one night and it was double
cast that year and that had never
happened in our time and to the other
cast got all the shows we got like one I
know anyway
but it we work so hard but we got to
that one song one man and it was
actually the first time because I grew
up seeing opera it was the first time I
found like my chest voice my gut like
and really started belting out and it
was like such a freeing boy what's the
difference though um it was like bass oh
you know Sister Act you know when she
does the thing with the stomach oh happy
day so it yeah it's just using oh it's
yeah it was just kind of switching gears
for me from doing opera needs to be so
perfect you have to be it became less
about perfection and technique and more
about passion and it was a really really
awesome moment for me I felt like I was
flying onstage
never told that story in my whole life
Wow are you looking for a co-host
patient yes I am and I still want to
hear you sing it but we can do that
later I know I can't remember it okay 37
we'll work on this yeah let's do it
let's do it I just lived that I look
like dr. evil holding like a you know
it's but he's on my team I just talked
about I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this